while some governors are using the covid
crisis to grab more
power and undermine their citizens
constitutional rights
my next guest is among those actually
trying
to preserve liberty while also saving
lives and he's taking on officials in
his own state to do it
georgia governor brian camp is suing the
city of atlanta
for mandating masks but mainly
for going back into lockdown this
morning atlanta's mayor responded
it is mind-boggling that this governor
wastes
resources on suing me personally
and our city council for mass mandate
and advisory
voluntary business recommendations and
guidelines
it is very clear that he is putting
politics over people
it is really a distraction from what the
real enemy is here
governor kemp joins me now exclusively
governor it's great to see you
what's your response to the mayor there
well laura let me tell you what's really
going on in georgia
i'm working very hard every day and have
been for
you know a long time now to protect the
lives as well as the livelihoods of my
fellow citizens
however we have people local mayors that
are playing politics they
you know want to go back to shelter in
place they want to
you know stop in person dime dining with
no
notice just pulling the rug out from
under people and i'm just not going to
allow that to happen we're fighting two
battles here now
one to protect lives but also to protect
livelihoods and so i filed a lawsuit
to stop them because those orders are in
conflict with the statewide order that
i have executed for the public health
state of emergency
well governor kemp there are those who
would say look
if the masks help in 10 percent of the
cases
then why isn't that good enough to just
say look you can
you can save some lives maybe they're
not a hundred percent
isn't that worth this ongoing mass
mandate some of these mayors have in
place what would your response to that
be
well i'll think a little different
differently on that um
you know dr toomey i'm still at
following the
health advice that she's given me she's
a 40-year epidemiologist harvard
educated great person a lot of
experience
as much as anybody in the country um i
don't feel like a mandate's needed for
georgians to do the right thing
we have existing orders on the books
laura and this is what's so frustrating
about
uh a lot of the locals that are playing
politics with this
is we have orders on the books that has
worked in the past that help us flatten
the curve it helped us stop the spread
they have the ability through my order
to use their law enforcement
to you know enforce those orders and
they're not doing that
and that's what i've been telling them
you know instead of having a government
mandate
enforce the orders that we have make
sure businesses are following the rules
people are socially distancing
i've been talking about people wearing a
mask as much as anybody
and i said today in my press conference
for for those that just
do not want to wear a mask if you have a
health condition that prevents it or
some sort of phobia or anything else
just socially distance yourself if
everybody does their part
we'll flatten the curve again we'll stop
the spread and we can continue to reopen
our economy
but it's so important that we do that i
mean we literally have people that are
living paycheck to paycheck they're
barely getting by
in this economic environment our
business owners you know the amount of
mortgages
aren't being paid on time is going up
and we're looking at
you know large companies like delta
airlines and others that in the
in the future if the economy doesn't
rebound you know they're going to be
forced to start laying people off so
we've got to keep our economy open but
also
fight the virus and protect lives and
that's what we're doing
governor kem this is kind of a you know
a controversial question but
do you think that there is something
else going on here
where there's some element within the
democrat party
who think a a shutdown yeah it probably
you know would save lives people would
be at home but that
that would actually pull the brakes on a
recovery which is obviously underway
before a presidential election i'm
asking that because that's what so many
of my
viewers are wondering saying wait a
second we know there are some hot spots
that are dealing with those but
you shut this economy down in in a lot
of states again and
we're a toast yeah people can't handle
it
you know i i wouldn't be able to speak
to their politics it certainly seems
like they're trying to undermine
our economic recovery um you know i'm as
concerned about the virus as anybody
we're working with our
local school leaders and our school
superintendent get to get schools open
uh you know i got just accosted when i
started opening businesses early on
by the left because they were making fun
of us opening barber shops and hair
salons and now they're saying that the
guidance that we had
you know having people wear a mask and
use ppe and
have these rules in places have kept the
spread down in our salons and barber
shops
so i don't i don't know i mean it's got
to be pandemic
politics but i know this talking to our
hospital ceos they cannot go through
what we did before they will not be
financially
viable it will bankrupt our hospitals
we've heard from restauranteers out
there that are like
if we have to shut down again if we have
to move away from in-person dining we're
out for good
now in our state can't afford that
finally sir really quick
university of georgia are they going to
be playing football in the fall
well i've told all the young people
including my daughters who are doing a
really good job of following guidance
most of the time
that our young folks need to wear a mask
if they're going out and they can't
socially distance and they've got to
follow the guidance and the advice if
they want college football
this fall you know that is like a
religion here in the south
i want to see it happen it's a huge
economic impact but we need it mentally
as a society right now
so that's why i'm asking everybody for
the next four weeks you know wear a mask
socially distance wash your hands and
follow the existing guidance that we
have it'll work
and flatten the curve governor great to
see you tonight thanks for fighting for
small businesses and parents and
people who want to go to school and uh
it's it's
inspiring to see i'm glad you're out
there doing it and best of luck to you
sir
god bless